check this out
from the washington washington examiner
black lives matter releases new list of
demands including permanently banning
trump from all digital media platforms
why why does black lives matter care
about one guy i thought black lives
matter was about empowering empowering
you know the black community and
stopping the you know police brutality
but i guess they're really concerned
with making sure the democrats win
that's one of their one of their new
demands
so this is it this is this is the proof
that their goal is to rewrite history
and control from this point on history
if nothing changes in 50 years trump may
as well not existed i once had a very
long uh phone conversation with a uh
facebook press representative who is
supposed to just give me like a canned
comment for my article but instead he
went on for 30 minutes trying to
persuade me that black lives matter is
not a political movement and when i say
that facebook is political because it
supports blm i'm wrong because black
lives matter is non-partisan and
non-political and everyone should
believe in black lives uh but yes this
non-partisan non-political organization
wants to uh to ban a uh one that wants a
president to be banned from office what
do you think
we'll say about donald trump in 50 years
at this at this space
they're going to say
he was uh he was a white supremacist
they say he was a violent white
supremacist he incited insurrection and
tried to destroy the country and he was
dutifully defeated by a powerful and
well-informed electorate who challenged
the fake news ecosystem that he had
created that that'll that'll be history
the pictures of him will make him look
grotesque he'll have a bright orange
face with tiny hands
and that's all people will know about
him
i i disagree with that i think what
they'll say is
uh that this current republican
candidate is way too extreme even donald
trump was more moderate than that you
know this is this is how it always goes
the last republican uh president was a
moderate and the uh the car the current
republican president of canada is way
too far way beyond there so george bush
is now a hero right whereas you know at
the time he was you know literally
hitler yeah but you look at george bush
now and george bush is parroting the
establishment and the woke left
so joy which loves him now but back but
back then they were like you know
uh you know that this good this guy uh
he's racist he hates black he doesn't
care about black
people blah blah blah
racist and they called romney sexist and
you know now these are all heroes of the
establishment so trump was a moderate
though compared to them and they called
him far right indeed yeah so they can't
have
you know
it's hilarious watching uh you know
looking at cnn and and you know the the
twitter accounts of some of their
personalities when they're just trapped
in this time vortex where january 20th
has never come and they're stuck there
with trump all around them and there and
the things they say about him i'm like
wikipedia and
the look universities in academia is
totally corrupted and tainted with bunk
insane information
they push lies every day you go on
reddit you see what people think they
think wrong things
because the media is no longer about
mainstream corporate press is it for a
long time has not been around to inform
people
it exists now to
misinform people on purpose
someone got smart and they are like man
you know these journalists maybe it was
the mob maybe it was these corrupt
politicians back in the day they were
like this journalist is going to expose
my affair i can't have that
i know let's buy the newspapers well
gobbles
hitler's prophet minister of propaganda
was
legit led spearheaded that charge when
they had they had basically had the
first time in history they had tv and
they could use media like that so they
decided if you tell a lie enough
eventually people will start to believe
it i wouldn't be surprised if people are
in the future told that there were
weapons of mass destruction in iraq and
that it was
trump's white supremacist followers who
are spreading lies i wouldn't even
surprise other people today that think
there were
like you would think that would be the
most
red flag we made a mistake thing to
teach kids but they don't want that and
i say they and i hate using they as a
bland thing but this this military
complex whatever you want to call it
military
capitalist
course of com whatever they they really
want to sell bullets
they need to and they're afraid that if
we don't police the world someone else
will i think it's way way more than that
i think that's that's overly simplistic
yeah i'm being kind because we're on tv
on the internet yeah on the internet i i
i don't think it's about necessarily
selling bullets about maintaining
dominance and it's not so much they're
scared someone else will police the
world it's that they want to maintain
dominance everybody wants more i think
it's i think it's fair to say there's
concerns about china's expansion in
russia but if they were really cared
about if they really cared about that
i'd imagine they'd be taking china more
seriously not being deferential to china
i think the reality is many politicians
are like look
i don't care who's in charge so long as
you keep giving me money and i get to be
super rich so when china starts doing
its thing they go what's the easiest way
to make money on this one just side with
china yeah the way to understand
american foreign policy policy i think
is that it for a long time it hasn't
been in the interest of the american
people or in even the american national
interest in terms of maintaining
dominance it's just been you know which
foreign lobbyists are throwing around
money which think tanks are throwing
around money that that you know that the
whole russia panic was driven by these
very powerful influential cross atlantic
think tanks like the atlantic council
um
and you know the german marshall fund
you know who their entire job is
predicated on a u.s focus on russia so
at the slightest hint that there might
be a pivot from rush to china these guys
freaked out which is why they became
some of the most anti-trump people out
there yep
yeah so history is written by the
victors yeah and
but then again there are also you know
people have an interest in a china focus
so it's just all these groups competing
man
i'm a bit uh
i don't know what the right word is
um pessimistic to say the very least
there are some there are some positive
things we've seen the olympics just
banned uh black lives matter protests
kneeling you know pumping your fist or
whatever
i think you know we've seen some some
hollywood stuff stuff that's been uh
anti-woke and it may be because now that
trump's out of office they're like okay
we better pull this back before we lose
control but regardless
the establishment is in control
i've had a cynical interpretation of the
olympic thing if the olympic committee
allowed political expression by uh you
know american athletes that have to
allow political expression from chinese
athletes
and north korean athletes actually it's
north korea boundary limits i don't know
but all these authoritarian regimes
would send their athletes and say hey uh
you know show that show the hammer and
sickle you know uh you know
hold a holder sign saying you know the
hong kong protesters are terrorists et
cetera et cetera yep so they'd have to
cave to all these other countries as
well that's probably why they did it
it's true and and i'd love to see more
protests against china but i'm i'm like
they're still allowed to protest just
not during the games so i'm like i mean
that's a good thing maybe everybody
needs to chill out a little bit this is
like you know the violence the
escalation
the problem is it's one-sided
it's it's the the people protesting
china aren't going around blowing things
up i mean hong kong there was you know
rioting but you look at in
in the u.s it's antifa
and and they're gaining ground and
they're winning
they're winning the legal battle they're
winning the media battle and the uh
federal law enforcement is acting like
they don't exist and giving them space
to just destroy everything
to inject some optimism the state laws
against critical race theory
that's a positive development lots of
red states too but but you know when you
were talking about the florida florida's
law on uh
social media censorship not being enough
yeah it's the same thing that's true for
these bans on critical race theory it's
not just critical race theory it's it's
it's wokeness encompasses critical
theory in general which is every aspect
of identity so now you've got a whole
bunch of people saying critical race
theory and they're totally ignoring
critical gender theory and you know
there's a whole slew of identity-based
you know theories that exist beyond race
so it's like
better than nothing
but still how are we supposed to catch
up if if we're going slower than they
are
they're not just passing laws they're
burning down buildings
cutting cutting off pigs heads and
putting on the porches of the of the
former home of one of the witnesses in
the chauvin trial they're lying to get
on the trials in the first place and the
good principled you know moderates and
disacted liberals and conservatives are
like well we're not going to do any of
that we shouldn't and if you even think
about doing it the fbi will go oh
and they'll send 12 agents down because
they found a garage pull rope in your
house
yeah the fbi is just like the
enforcement arm of the uh the democrat
controlled oligarchy at this point it
was it was during trump as well it was
yes yeah
yeah so uh forgive me for being a little
bit pessimistic huh you know what well
politically yeah i think it's busted af
but
i think the real solution is technology
like if we can
have water um decentralized water supply
for every human and we're able to travel
and live spread out i think a lot of
these problems will dissipate
so although it is important to focus on
these this political stuff china america
black lives matter violence in the
streets but it's not the solution i
don't think it's the solution i have no
amount of arguing and yelling and
signing paperwork's gonna solve it we
need technology that can allow us to
become independent yeah the technology
is currently owned and controlled by the
cult so
proprietary technology is concerning and
ip wasn't even invented so i think queen
elizabeth uh created copyright in order
to protect the bibles that she wanted to
sell so that she could maintain profit
on all the bibles before that that
didn't exist you could just kind of
trade information freely now i think ip
should exist well i mean should be
reformed somebody with software code i
think somebody who works you know 100
hours to make a feature-length film
should be compensated for producing that
work and people saying it's just
information i can share it all i want
it's like okay like
someone worked really hard to make
something they want to sell that's why
crypto works that's why crypto is so
powerful because you can't duplicate it
it's it's it's a it's a non-duplicatable
asset you can have digitally
i like the idea like if you made a movie
and wanted to sell it for 9.99 for
someone to watch it and then i got a
hold of it and wanted to sell it for a
buck for people to watch it
that 90 of those profits would go to you
automatically
so if you could somehow code into the
software that no matter where it goes
and who profits off of it always goes
back to the creator at least a large
percentage
we're i'm getting off off topic a little
bit yeah this is yeah i guess the main
topic is i'm interested in this actually
i mean i think uh you were saying
earlier about how all these uh hollywood
studios would judge regurgitate stuff
and you know do the same formulas again
and again the same remakes again and
again if they didn't have full control
of the if they didn't have full control
over the ips and you know as you say if
people out you know reproduce
and create new stuff off of that ip
and all the profits
or a significant amount of the profits
go back to the creator then i think
you'd see a lot more creativity
yeah definitely creative commons things
like that i don't know though it's
decentralized from the internet you know
there used to be a small amount of
really big bands and movie producers and
movie stars who made a lot of money and
now because movie theaters are going
away and because spotify exists and
everything's decentralizing this is
actually what i think is contributing to
the destruction of our culture and
society that people can choose whatever
they want so it used to be that
everybody's like what do you watch well
you can watch the news or you can watch
the oscars so everybody would watch the
oscars whether they liked it or not it
was what was on now the oscars comes on
it's like
what did we watch during the oscars i
don't remember we watched something oh
mortal kombat i was watching mortal
kombat instead because it came out
the movie it's the citizen kane of our
generation excellent excellent film yes
just just totally amazing and i didn't
watch the oscars it's so extreme too how
many videos are on youtube guess the
billions billy you have billions of
choices of things to watch during the
oscars you used to have like 70 maybe if
you had like five before that you had
five yeah abc nbc now you have billions
of things to watch
static things that always are there to
watch there's no schedule there's no you
have to wait till eight o'clock i mean
it's a different reaction this is why
elites are so scared of the internet
though because it's taken away that
shared reality and you know there were
downsides to taking away shared reality
but it took away a shared reality that
they controlled and that's what they're
afraid of right
now people find whatever community they
want for whatever they want to believe
and then you end up with people
believing in saying things
so it's funny i i love how you know cnn
is obsessed with like q anon and and
trumpism and i'm just like
the level of damn like the the level of
cultism within like the fringe q anon
people
is identical to the zealotry of the woke
left but the woke left is
institutionally accepted spouting
ridiculous insane fake news nonsense
every single day i think i think one of
the most uh
dangerous people on tv i love left is
like tucker carlson is dangerous i
actually think one of the most dangerous
would probably be like chris cuomo
and uh tapper and then to a lesser
degree you know people like brian selter
their jobs are to misinform you to make
sure you don't understand the world it's
like they're purposefully trying to make
you see things incorrectly so that you
can't do anything about it case in point
i think it was was it tapper when he was
like was he the one who said you
couldn't look at the wikileaks documents
or was that cuomo it was one of them
definitely one of them they were like
don't don't forget these wikileaks
emails you can't look at them it's
illegal but we're allowed to do it and
then they can all all right what they
want to make sure you don't know things
brian stelter on history goes don't
watch the spin make sure you come to us
we're the only ones who can bring you
the truth
i'm like you guys are crazy
yeah i mean you look at the shared
reality created by you know
institutional uh corporate media you
know they believe in sane things about
you know white supremacy and feminism
and the patriarchy and they believe this
for decades and decades and i think the
other key and on thing and they're just
insane that they now have to compete
with other insane realities i mean the q
and on thing is not relevant in my
opinion it's i mean sure there's a lot
of people on the internet who believe
things that are not true i know people
who believe the earth is flat because
they went on the internet and read some
weird website
then i opened vox
and they're repeating
fringe conspiracy theories they did it
for years bill maher i love i love how
it's one of the sweetest things like one
of the funniest things to see bill maher
get corrupted because he's this proud
like rational guy
who's like oh religion is crazy and i
think and oh these republicans are so
dumb and now it's like he's coming out
and admitting yeah russia gate wasn't
real
it's like but dude for years you were
prattling on about it did you not take
two seconds out of your day you
spineless coward to actually read the
news no because people at this age and
this point in their careers they sit
back with their eyes half closed bill
maher probably sparked up a doobie and
then said just do the work for me i'm
done and so then some dumb intern turns
on cnn and just writes down what he
hears is here bill here's your criticism
and then bill comes out a week after
covington
a week after covington when everything
was debunked and says all of the the bs
lines and i'm like bro
do you have google
well uh you know what i can't blame them
because google's banning certain news
exactly they're pointing him to
confirmation bias a lot of times people
are getting pointed towards articles
that confirm what they want to believe
and now he's he's supposed to be the
same the same liberal guy
i appreciate the fact that he pushes
back on the wokeness
but his talking points are just
regurgitated fake news and the dude
doesn't have
the wherewithal to actually know what
he's talking about more so than many
others to be fair they want us to you
know uh believe that the scariest most
dangerous conspiracy theories are the
ones on you know anonymous message
boards but the conspiracy theories we
should be worried about are the ones
that exist in universities and in the
cnn newsroom because they're the ones
that have influence yeah like the uh
project veritas exposing the technical
director who's like we got trump out
it's what we do and we're going to be
fear-mongering going covet death oh man
gangbusters for ratings these people are
sick
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you